I so yeah as already said I'm going to
be talking about cookie cutter today and
I'm really excited to be here today
that's the first pie data for me
actually and I'm really surprised or
like not surprised but very happy with
how it's been so far so thank you very
much to all the organizers it's a great
event just a little bit about myself so
my name is Raphael and I'm currently
based in Berlin I have lived in
Edinburgh in Scotland for the past one
and a half years but I'm German
originally so if you're interested in
Scotland you could talk to me afterwards
I'm a maintainer and core developer of
the cookie cutter project I also
contribute to PI tests and plugins and
everything around that and sometimes I
act a bit as a community person so I
talk on podcasts or I beat the
development sprint at your place and for
instance I'm also the creator of the
template the cookie cutter pie test
plugin and we'll talk about that later
on and my day job is a software engineer
at a company called move o we work in
the field of urban mobility and I use
Python and go so if any of that is
interesting to you can find me
afterwards we can talk I'm also on
social media
hacker broad is my twitter handle and my
github username I'll post links to my
slides later on on my Twitter and the
agenda for today's first of all I want
to talk about what cookie cutter
actually is the second I want to kind of
show you and explain to you how cookie
cutter works then we'll have a brief
look into how you can create your own
template so if you have maybe best
practices in your team at work or in
your open source project it might be a
good idea to create a template from that
and those all new projects based on that
templates and then we'll have a look at
some popular cookie cutter templates and
they vary quite a bit in the scope so
some of them are really minimal they
only get you started but there are also
templates which kind of would strap your
entire web allocation and I think that's
really powerful so we'll have a look at
that and then at the end there will be a
short demonstration of how you actually
use cookie cutter and since we are at PI
data there is a great template for
creating custom Jupiter widget
so I'll demonstrate other works so what
is cookie cutter that's first of all is
our amazing logo I think it's well
showing we can find it on github it's
hosted under authorized user animal
that's Audrey our slash cookie cutter
you might not order a from she's one of
the authors of the two scoops of jungle
book series and Audrey and her husband
Danny Daniel they worked on the project
originally but they're still maintained
as all the projects and this is how
cookie cutter works you usually use a
command line interface and then you just
run the executable and then you specify
a template that you want to use the
generated project we support a number of
abbreviations so in that case you can
see we reference github and then we say
from the PI test dev organization we
want to use the cookie cutter Plata's
plugin template and then once cookie
cutter clones the repository for you it
will ask you for input so it prompts you
like one after another first it asked me
for my full name and then in the square
brackets you can see that's the default
value so when I hit return it will just
use the default but you are also free to
provide your own values as you can see
with the blue font size on the right
hand side so for instance the plug-in
name the default would be fubar but I
decided to use the Emoji instead and in
the end the three lines that's log
output from hooks so there is a
mechanism that allows you to you as a
template author to run arbitrary code in
Python or AB a script before you
generate the project and I'm also once
the project is generated and that comes
in really handy sometimes
and then if everything is successful you
will have this directory structure for
this particular template and you can see
we provided this name of emoji and you
can find it in the root directory there
is also a five-person script I test
emoji and there's also test test emoji
so you can already figure that well
cookie cutter does something with your
input and creates files and directories
based on that as already mentioned we're
on github you can find the documentation
and read the docs and we are also on the
path of packaging and X under cookie
cutter we support all major platforms
the Windows Mac OS Linux and a whole
range of thousand words x and the target
project they can be of any arbitrary
programming language or markup format so
you can still use cookie cutter as
someone who doesn't use Python and I
think that's really handy so yeah and
this is how you install cookie cutter
from IP I just did which if you're on
Mac OS and you like homebrew as a
package manager you can use homebrew as
a-brewin so cookie cutter there's also
something set up for the new users among
us or if you use Conda there's also a
cookie cutter on the Conda Forge there's
a quite a large community by now and
it's published and distributed under a
permissive BSD 3 license so you can even
go to projects on top of the project I
think that's really helpful and there
are by now there are among around like
160 individual contributors from around
the world there are more than a thousand
templates on github already so I think
the chances of finding something that
goes into the direction that you want to
graduate project for I think is there
you can also contribute we have a chat
and everyone is invited to contribute so
if you're interested or you have
questions just find me afterwards and we
can talk them so I can try to help you
get started contributing so how does it
work first of all the two things to
mention here so you can use either the
Commons line interface as we saw earlier
or you can import cookie cutter and use
kind of the engine from your Python
script so you don't need to use the
comment line if you don't want to there
are a number of options to for instance
change the level of verbosity but you
can also suppress the prompting
altogether and provide all the values by
yourself from the Python API for
instance that's the common line
interface so as we are already you use
the executable then you provide a number
of options if you want to then the
template and there is something called
the extra context and what it does can
we can look at an example here
so we enable the verbose mode and we say
we don't want to prompt the user for
input so we use the non or no input flag
here then we say we want to use the PI
to flag and template and then that's the
extra context so we know that there is a
variable called license and we already
choose that we want to use a BSD 3
license
the default is MIT I think for the
template and we also say we want to use
documentation and generate that as
things so that's kind of the extra
context is a way of overwriting the
defaults and they're not prompting so I
think that cut a nice way of not having
to prompt the user for input from the
Python API API you just import cookie
cutter from the main module pass the
template to it and it pretty much so how
does it work so behind the scenes there
is on the front there is click what we
use for the prompting but in the back
there is ginger and ginger as a project
and that's a templating engine that is
modeled after the one from Django so if
you use templating and web projects you
might know them gingers also and flask
for instance and it's really really
powerful and that's why I decided to use
that so whenever you see something with
those curly braces that's some for you
and indicated that there's something
happening with some templates the magic
so in the first case you can see so
that's just an opossum script and you
can see there is the curly brace curly
brace cookie cutter dot plug-in name so
we reference a variable called plugin
name here and then just also for the
keyword argument of default there is
some extra magic here which is a
function call and we'll look into that
just in a bit you can also use filters
which is really powerful yes so as you
can see here in the line with a module
name we reference the plug-in name but
then we apply a lower filter to it so we
make sure that the value is all
lowercase or characters or lowercase and
then we replace every item with an
underscore so you can kind of chain
together all your filters and use one
output for the input of the next one
we support a different version control
systems so you can use a remote template
or you can lose a local template and
four remotes we support git and
mercurial and there's currently no
people requests by Russell keys McGee to
support zip files so you can provide an
elf URL to a zip archive and we'll
download that extract it and use the
template that's included in there but
that's not where Shore released yet but
we're working on that so how do you
create your own cookie cutter template
so first of all there are two things to
mention here you need a directory that
needs to follow this templating syntax
so it needs to be templated and then you
need a file called cookie cutter JSON so
when we start create a new directory for
our projects and then we create this
templated root directory for the
generated project we use the syntax here
to say that the name of our root the
directory for the generated project
should be the value of project slack so
that's something that the user would
enter in the case that I showed earlier
would be the og saying for instance and
if we go into that directory and we from
this project lock and you can see that
we also have this cookie cutter dot
something so that's kind of the
namespace that we always have to use and
then you kind of need to know that
whatever we get you register or use as a
variable you need to register that in
the cookie cutter Jason context file so
that's like those two ways first the
directory and then you have the
directory and then you have the cookie
cutter Jason so then if you for instance
want to create a Python script you use a
new variable name called script name and
use the file extension for a platform
file here and put in this content so we
define a function called hello pi data
and then we just print hello pi data and
then the value of the location variable
so we used three variables essentially
and we need to register them in this
context so we go to the root directory
of a template project and create this
and that's all you need to put in there
so all the variables that we
you threw out our template need to be
registered here and provided with the
default so project slug just project for
instance location world and the script
name we can use a template syntax
already in the cookie cutter Jason so
that's how you for instance lowercase
something to be compliant with tab aid
in your Python projects so that's the
hole template that's all you need to
have a very very minimal cookie cutter
project and then if you run that you can
use a local path as well it will ask you
please provide a project clock the
default is project and we say hello
project location the default is world
what we decide to use buildin is that
and then in the script name you can
already see that this templating works
interactively so from the last question
that knows that our location is not
world but Berlin and it changed the
default for script name to accommodate
for that so then if it runs Russell
that's the generated project for us and
if we run as you can see it prints out
hello pi data and then the location
variable value I think that's pretty
cool
so about ginger whenever you see those
curly braces you already know there's
something going on with ginger and I was
essentially just three things to keep in
mind whenever you see something with
curly braces and percentage you know
it's a statement so there is some kind
of function some kind of logic that's
being executed if you see something with
two curly braces that always the value
for the template variable but that's
just the string kind of it's inserted
there and then you can also have comment
in your ginger templates which will not
be included in the rendered output for
your template so what's really handy I
think are the control structures in
ginger so you can for instance have a
for loop in your template and you
probably know that from when you're
working with web apps for instance you
iterate over some sort of data and for
all of the data you create a new row in
your HTML table or something you can
also have if statements so he can decide
based on the user input if you want to
do something or something else
and you can also use macro
and macros are kind of a way of how you
can put some logic some template logic
and define it in a macro and then import
it and reuse it throughout your template
so you don't need to repeat the template
logic everywhere and in that particular
case for this example I'm using
restructure text you for my readme file
but you know when you define a heading
and a researcher text file you have the
text and then you need to have a second
line and then put as much many equal
signs in the next line as you would have
characters on the first line that's how
you define a heading in a restructured
text format I think that's really
tedious if you need to do that by hand
every time so it's it's a nice way of
defining a macro and it will just copy
the the value and replace all of the
characters with an equal sign so that's
how you would for instance user heading
in a restructure text there are also
certain console structures which kind of
help you to create more powerful
templates you can use assignments so
your template can have its own local
variables you can also use includes and
what that is it is I think best shown
here and an example that would be a
license file for the generator project
so rather than having just one license
in my templates I like to kind of give
my users the option of choosing from a
set of different licenses for the open
source projects but then rather than
copying all of the license texts into
this one single filer making super hard
to maintain I have this logic in here
that references the folder so you can
see there is an include and then it
takes MIT for instance from this license
directory so when the user decides hey I
want to use the MIT license my template
will include the rendered template from
from well the templates for the MIT
license text I think it's really good
they also filters and we already had a
look at that so you can have a replace a
lower and upper and there's so many
built-in filters already
thank we we've talked about this before
they're also more powerful ones you can
sort for instance you can sort a
sequence of items and even like based on
an attribute so if you have a structure
I don't know some object and as an
attribute you can sort by that and then
do something with your template and
there have also select a group by and I
think you kind of get the idea you can
use different filters for different
things and I think it's best to look at
the gender to documentation that's a
really good point where you can get
started look in this
there are also extensions so if you have
the same template logic and repeated all
over again it makes sense to encapsulate
that put it into an extension and maybe
even publish that on PI P I and in this
particular case in cookie cutter we have
one exemption called ginger time because
users oftentimes are prompted for the
current year and that's feel that the
user is kind of ridiculous like why do
you need to put in the current year here
so we decided to write an extension for
that and for instance in the MIT license
text there is a requirement that you
kind of when you say with the copyright
holder you have the current year and
then you have the the author's name so
that's how you would do that with cookie
cutter and ginger so you can see there
is this now function that comes with the
extension you safe from the UTC time
zone and then some Python string format
for outputting the year so just to
mention a couple of popular cookie
cutter up templates so you can maybe
have a look at them later on there's one
for Python packages so with a template
you can create a new parsing project
that already follows the best practices
for parsing projects the design later
can upload to pi PI so it has a set up
py set up it has a manifest yam set up
and all of that stuff you have also
testing you can choose from either unit
tests or PI tests you can also have
talks to another testing project with
which you can test your code against
different Python versions and it has
things for documentation then there's
also cookie cutter Jango which is from
Daniel
and this is one of the ones where you
have so many different features and you
get those like the whole web application
bootstrapped they have an optimized
development and production settings so
that's really nice debugging setup and
rhetorics and all of it they have docker
support bootstrap and the sheer endless
list of features so you should
definitely have a look at that if you
want to see how kind of how complex the
template can be and there's also this
very minimal one where you can use this
template to create a poetess plugin so
there is a convention when you want to
create your des plugin how you need to
set up the set of tools entry points so
that PI test will understand that hey
this is a PI test blog and we read
properly and all of that stuff and the
template takes care of that it also has
a couple of examples for fixtures and
comment line options and all of that
stuff as I mentioned you can choose from
different licenses open tools licenses
and then if you are interested for
instance in building a Python app for an
iOS device the awesome people from the
PI B wear project they have a template
here PI test iOS template with which you
can create a Python project that runs
your app on iOS which is kind of nice
and works well with the toga toolkit
which is also under the private wear
umbrella so now for just a very quick
demo how you would use cookie cutter to
create a custom Jupiter widget that's
the template that I use I kind of forced
it made some changes to include emoji
because emoji are awesome so just look
at that so the first thing that we that
we do is we say we want to use cookie
cutter and say please use the widget
cookie cutter there's also a feature in
cookie cutter with which you can check
out the branch so it can say please take
the emoji branch and then github for
instance on my username and then I say
widget cookie cutter and then ask me if
I want to clone it again because I've
done that already
then it asked me for my also name
and there is also a feature called user
config so in my home directory I have
this cookie cutter RC file in which I
register certain variables to some
default values so the original template
has a different author name but in that
particular case it takes whatever I have
in my user conflict and I'm happy with
that the github project name I'll just
say emoji widget get a user name that's
okay
Python package name NPM awesome emoji
widget which emoji widget and then it
asked me for a default emoji and that's
really just for the sake of the
presentation here going with coffee
because coffee is good and then I have a
virtual environment set up here I go
into the generated project and the
template has an install script here that
installs to Peecher it installs my
widget project and then what it does it
uses the jupiter api to register my
extension so everything is nice here and
then if i run it typical notebook see
that okay
oh cool so creating a person three
notebook and from emoji oops import
hello world and I'm creating a new
widget and then I'm just laying that and
it says hi I'm Rebecca Gina so that's
the author name that we provided in the
template and then it uses coffee which
was one of the options of greeted fund
and input as well and just to
demonstrate that you can also do
something differently here how the world
can we say text nope emoji other angry
and answers hey sorry this emoji is not
supported yep
so this I think kind of gives you an
impression of how you would use cookie
cutter to generate a new project and the
project just works kind of I think
that's really nice okay and I think
that's that's pretty much it I also
wanted to draw your attention to this we
have a kind of not a fundraiser but so
cookie cutter development is entirely
run on volunteers time we kind of
decided to create a patreon page so if
you're interested in supporting our
project because you or your company are
using cookie cutter already as part of
your development process please check
out the site and if you have any
questions talk to me afterwards that's
me on Twitter and github and I would be
happy to take any questions if you have
any
[Applause]
how do you develop the template so I
think like there is no certain way of
how everyone does it
what I usually do is because I like to
test my coders right working code first
and then kind of do a global search and
replace so for instance I develop a new
podcast plugin and I want to create a
template out of that I would first
develop all of the plug-in logic and
then always use the same string that I
can easily done globally search and
replace with a cookie cutter variable
template then might become very easy
well yeah it depends right I mean
depending on how you prepare there yeah
I mean there is I think that's the best
way of how you could do that and
following Abed
so how do you then test the cookie
cutter template code on a continuous
integration platform
yes so now it's getting funky I like to
combine thing things so I wrote a pipers
plugin to create a Tory to test cookie
cutter templates and it's called PI test
cookies so so you would use PI test to
use the Python API of cookie cutter and
then this plugin provide some kind of
nice API to see if there was an error
during generation and also to influence
the input of the user to replicate that
okay and one completely different
question about licenses we already saw
that those options with MIT starting and
going to GPL and step propriety but it
seems that most project don't realize
that they doing big mistakes because
they license their project so their
templates under like BT but they give
the option to do it
this is not really applicable canister
what I mean
not quite I think the cookie cutter well
it's not really your problem but it it's
getting enhanced like that Jango who had
a Jango is licensed and under VC but you
get the question if you want to license
your project you create with the
templating thing I'm on the MIT but this
is not you essentially couldn't do it
they couldn't allow that but they did
also two different things right so the
one is like the logic that you get from
the template which maybe use the MIT
license for that but then the question
that you get while prompting is kind of
what license do you want to use for the
generated project and the generated
project doesn't have any kind of back
references to the templates does that
make sense understand it but I think
it's just not you it couldn't be done
like you can't license the code
differently then later on it would have
had to be right here in the first place
yeah well maybe we can talk about that
on the hallway later on
what do you think is the greatest
advantage of cookie cutter in comparison
to other good generation tools so I've
been asked at previous conferences if I
use yeoman which is part of the
JavaScript community and I think there
are there is a list of different code
generation tools the reason I use cookie
cutters because I I don't know a saml of
crosses and I like the project and the
authors I like it because it's written
in Python and it's fairly easy I think
there is no company behind it which has
it's good sides but also we don't have
any funding so it's bad and as a user I
would say why would you use cookie
cutter over something else
the biggest advantage for me is because
it's using ginger so if you already work
with person you are familiar maybe with
the Django templating engine or if you
use slask you're already know ginger so
the only thing that you really need to
know like if you want to get started
with cookie cutter is how you use it but
the underlying templating might already
be familiar to you as a person engineer
I think that's pretty cool any other
questions
so thank you